the fight over limits on abortion is
spreading to some unexpected places
including drug stores at least one
medication commonly prescribed for
arthritis lupus and even cancer is
becoming harder to get after the supreme
court allowed states to restrict or
outlaw abortions janet chamblin has a
story of patients who are caught in the
middle and dreading the possible impact
on their health
nora wise has been living with a rare
autoimmune disease that causes
inflammation in her bones for a while
her mom says there was no relief we were
doing therapies and
everything we could but her pain kept
increasing
and she would be crying
all night long the 10 year old indiana
girl says the worst pain was in her
lungs it felt like i didn't want to
breathe it just felt like needles but
life changed her mom says after noora's
doctor prescribed methotrexate we
started the methotrexate
it took about two weeks
and she said she wasn't in pain anymore
methotrexate slows the body's immune
system and reduces inflammation it's
commonly used to treat rheumatoid
arthritis in some cancers but can also
be used to terminate non-viable ectopic
pregnancies where a fertilized egg grows
outside the womb since the supreme court
decision that overturned roe v wade some
women report trouble getting the
medication by pharmacists concerned they
could be held responsible for aiding an
abortion as soon as i started hearing
about women in other states having this
issue
i
started asking the question is this
going to be a problem annie england
nobland is a long-term user of
methotrexate for rheumatoid arthritis
but says a pharmacy recently put her
refill on hold they needed to make sure
that my rheumatologist actually
prescribed me methotrexate
for my ra and not so that i could you
know abort a fetus nopeland lives in
missouri a state banning almost all
abortions when you heard that
what did you think it was immediate
anger i was embarrassed because i was in
a pharmacy line
and i
i said
okay do you also need to know the first
date of my last period as well john
thopel is an ob gyn doctor practicing in
texas another state where most abortions
are illegal this is a common thing we
deal with he's prescribed methotrexate
about 10 times over the last year to end
non-viable pregnancies and is concerned
about potential delays in patients
getting it are there other medications
that can do what this drug does
unfortunately for treatment of ectopic
pregnancy no you know so if this is
delayed there's a time line that this
works the pregnancy gets too far along
the only thing left is surgery for nora
wise the medication is a game changer
she wants to keep taking i know the
medicine works i don't have any more
pain it's just i hope
that
i'll have my medicine
for cbs morning's janet chamleon austin
texas